Sal what are you worse at like history
cuz you didn't even know like there was
a civil war you know what world war two
was you didn't know fought in World War
two like a you were said pronouncing
English words or history so history is
your mortal enemy not the English
language you screw up a lot of words
it's almost like you're from another
country valent relevant he is Italian
yeah but but he grew up in America
aterna izing for turnin izing returnin
izing he's really bad at geography too I
think for usually know where anything is
like I'm not great at geography but he
easily he didn't even know like there
was a Europe yeah I don't think he knew
there was Alaska there's something we
were the last day to know Africa so what
sounds you know where Madagascar is
numeric is it Madagascar no in Africa it
is Asia they begin with an A did you
think there were three oceans I want to
ask myself how many oceans are there
let's say you have Atlantic which is
East Coast you know any of the
continents mmm I know the continents now
how many how many are there seven what
are they you have North America South
America Antarctica Asia Africa Europe
and what am I missing baby babe all
right coach hey dude I wasn't bad he is
learning center each
we taught them on the air